okay if you if your youtube channel dies
are you
are you a successful youtuber
well i mean
okay if your youtube channel dies but if
you want successful uh were you are you
a successful youtube channel well it
depends
like there's plenty of people who say
you're a failed youtuber there's there's
kind of people who are still succeeding
on like other platforms it depends how
your channel died yeah
you know like if you if if you killed it
with your own volition and like because
of something you did yeah then like you
know maybe oh yeah but i don't i don't
buy the whole thing
the algorithm [ __ ] me over [ __ ] off
not like that if it's like if it's like
you know if someone just said like if
you're a really successful youtuber and
one day you're just like you know what i
kind of want to do something else and
then just like peace out then i think
you can say you're a successful youtuber
if you got canceled for some [ __ ]
maybe not if you had like a slow decline
your videos weren't really improving
you'd be kind of stagnated you know your
channel kind of fizzled out um
i don't think in in that case that
you're a failed youtuber everyone not
every everyone will peak eventually you
know that's just that's just a part of
life and that's just part of the
platform it's just a matter of like when
you think it's the right time to end it
you know like yeah because some people
or some people don't even end it but
they are you know they're still living
pretty comfortably and they're still
getting decent enough views on what they
do it's just not nearly the same level
as what they were doing in that what's
your definition of a successful youtuber
what's success to you connor yeah
money theme
pyramid scheme i don't know just uh
like because because there's so many
youtubers now then i'm just like
whatever happened to them i mean it's
you know it's one of those things where
let's it's very hard to tell someone to
do the exact same thing they're doing
for half the money yeah you know it's
it's just mentally it's it's a hard
thing to do yeah regardless of how good
the money still is or how you know it's
very difficult to tell someone hey just
accept you're doing half as good as you
were last month yeah you know what i
mean because that's something that takes
a toll on you because you know you you
know you're capable of getting what you
had yeah and yet how do you
you know because especially if it's like
more than just one person if there's a
team of you it's impossible to get the
team everyone on the team to be like
yeah dude let's just keep doing what
we're doing for half the money yeah you
know
that's the top that's it's just the
reality of it yeah do the same thing for
half the paycheck you know because stuff
like uh
god i don't know like uh
yogscast or whatever when they were
making like i don't know [ __ ] a
billion dollars or something from
minecraft yeah or game grumps yeah how
do you how do you convince the gang to
stay together
when the money is going as well this
sounds like a [ __ ] prelude
what if we start getting less views we
get we're getting here 800k views an
episode see you guys
we're done we're done
what's that twitter page where it's just
like things that have aged horribly yeah
just just see this clip getting posted
in like three years or something man
although i mean you know i feel like in
terms of that you know uh
i feel like it depends on what you are
doing like if you have an insane
schedule
it's the the likelihood is gonna be
there where you're gonna be more likely
to quit if the money isn't as good if
the schedule is intense you know trash
takes me just telling once and we can
[ __ ] talk
i can't see uh any time soon where this
becomes a burden to my life no no oh
[ __ ] i don't talk once a week oh my god
talk to my best mate oh my god
well again like okay so then taking that
same you know like hypothetical that you
were saying right like let's put that in
the case with trash taste right right so
like would you get half the views would
you say that in like you know i would
give however many years time if we were
getting half or a quarter of the views
right yeah i i just want to talk i don't
give a [ __ ] i don't know we i wasn't
expecting a million views anyway you
know i don't i don't care if you know
how
i was prepared for like
we were prepared for 100k after a year
we've said this many times
at the end of the day this is and it
always has been a passion project and i
just want to talk yeah yeah i've got a
big mouth i i wanna
i wanna just talk with my friends you
know and i wanna have an outlet to do
that um whether that's narcissistic you
can judge for yourself i don't know i
don't know what it is i don't know if i
need to see a psychiatrist about it i
don't know but um
yeah uh it's just that was what it was
for me it was never a it was never a
business venture it was already we never
planned for this to be like as
successful as i mean obviously it's not
more success obviously if we can make
good money we'll make good money and
we'll do what we can but obviously if it
stops making money i'm not going to care
but
because i have i have other things that
i'm doing and it's i never try and put
all my eggs in one basket but you know
in cases where there were channels where
people's whole career was riding on it
it's hard to i find it is hard to
convince people to stay on board when
the money is like one third one
half you know it's
it's it's hard well i think in that case
it does like you do have to kind of
follow your passion right follow because
you're not gonna be happy grinding out
the same same content that you've been
making that really shows if you are
passionate as well if yeah if it does if
it does plummet yeah for some reason
but also again there has to be a
question that has to be a question has
been answered there is like okay if the
views did half
something has gone wrong whether you
like to admit it or not something has
gone wrong and it's not always the
algorithm sometimes okay on the freak
accident you know with the whole uh okay
okay okay i'm about to yoga it doesn't
even [ __ ] know it you're sketching
the channel what happened to you so
you're scared of the channel that made
uh uh minecraft videos and they didn't
really
you know you could blame the group you
could blame the algorithm and yeah there
was a time when the algorithm was
changing but if one thing has been
proven minecraft has been everlasting on
youtube yeah and clearly what's needed
to be done was to change the content
yeah right and they didn't change the
content
so
you know time and time again
youtube has proven that it is more often
than not not youtube's fault yeah yes if
you're an animator you've been [ __ ]
over yeah but also
animation channels are still doing well
so you have to change what you're doing
i mean there's there's animation
channels that have done well because
they've
uh adapted their kind of work
you know everyone wants to demonize
youtube and they they change the
algorithm and it is what it is you know
at the end of the day
you as youtubers you're on borrowed time
yeah it's always changing
you should have known better when you
were getting into this it was always
changing yeah you you you are you are
building a foundation on quicksand you
should have been changing that
foundation as you're building this tower
constantly and and so when i get angry
when i see these youtubers who complain
about their youtube video being
demonetized on twitter they throw it
fast that it's not being it's not
getting the same views and i want to
reply to them but we're mutuals and
we're supposed to be civil and i want to
i want to just slap them and be like
listen you know what's going on don't
don't try and get your your fans to
shout at youtube they get enough [ __ ]
yeah and there are youtubers uh i won't
name them but there's a lot of them who
still do it who constantly complain at
youtube but it pisses me off because i'm
like this is not youtube's fault this is
your fault yeah and the fact that you
can't see that or maybe you do see it
and you don't care it's really annoying
yeah
you also can answer the channel that
made i should go into that you should
talk about
which yogurt made uh minecraft videos
and their channels started dying because
they didn't really change it up and it's
just over like two or three years so
they had plenty of time to change it up
um and more often than not there is
there is a obvious factor at play that
went wrong
yeah
whatever that might be
was that the end of the point yeah well
we thought we were going to state the
obvious point i already said with
yogscast you know like they just didn't
change their content okay cause the way
he ended up was like and then there was
an obvious reason
you know uh
you ended that
like you ended that sentence in a
comment so obviously it's so obvious
it's so obvious that i don't need to
state it
i'll tell you the reason
i'm so knowledgeable about youtube ryan
higa right here yeah he just doesn't
upload anymore what do you mean he just
stopped uploading every every video that
ryan did outside of the podcast did well
yeah like when he did a you know when he
actually tried it did well like he just
wanted to become a touch streamer
congratulations ryan you succeeded in
doing what you wanted no exactly that's
what i'm saying i still think he's a
successful youtuber he's like not
pulling the numbers of his peak but like
to me that that doesn't matter because
it's you like you're everyone will reach
a point where they've reached the peak i
mean i i even i think i've reached the
peak that i can reach making anime
content right now there is just like to
me there's just like a cap of like just
purely anime content and like it's
i've tried for years to break through
that cap but i just don't think the
audience is there at the moment